we need to talk about this mustache I
told you it would get this time to shine
you're looking very dashing right now
and I really like this and then to
discover that you and Cole are in a
quote violent facial hair competition
break it down for me who's the judge of
this hairy competition the world is the
judge and the gods just look at this
anyone who's watching this please just
Google Cole Sprouse is mustache and do a
side-by-side then you be the judge see
the voluptuous point on this - I really
like it I trendy you've gone food bit
more of the chin point and he's gone for
more of the evil villain mustache twirl
are you thinking your Styles definitely
this entire encounter just I think
highlights for the public who really is
the evil twin take that on on its own
merit but he looks like a guy who ties
people to train tracks right like he
needs a top hat and a monocle I look
like a paladin warrior this is true I'm
liking where you go with this have you
been able to stay in touch with Cola how
see how's he doing he's going through a
lot right now on top of a global
pandemic no you sir I mean he's living
Amon KJ in the very beginning of
quarantine ended up staying together in
cages place in LA so they're isolating
together which is very cute and I've
heard a lot of cute stories I think
they're just lifting weights and eating
cheese I don't know I think that's what
they do
so he's good he's getting healthy he's
relaxing and and I talked to him every
day we still FaceTime every day for
every year of my life I love that he
must be so excited for sun-eater to come
out he was one of your earliest people
to read this he must be so proud
definitely I mean I also think that he
brings a perspective to sun-eater which
i think is obviously very valuable
having experienced the same things I
experienced he's particularly supportive
but at the same time I think that with
his angle he's able to see exactly what
I mean to get across and whether or not
that's getting across from my own
experience and his own experience
whether or not that's telling the right
story so when I've sent him edits it's
been usually
I'm very humbled and I feel very good at
the support that I've gotten for
sun-eater rings not only by my family
and friends but also by people as well
reacting to it I feel like it's been I
think there's always a risk in your
writer to take a chance and publish
something that you may internally feel
insecure about or might feel like we'll
never be ready for the public and to do
so and to show so much
public support it's been it's been
really nice
[Music]